everybody's gamescom 2014 Sean McGinnis
and seb board we just checked out a
little bit of quantum break yes was
interesting because we got to see what
happens after the press conference demo
yeah we saw yesterday is platforming
quite a bit of a time problem that's how
I achieve is it yeah so that that demo
just to do a little bit of a recap yeah
it's very combat heavy haha me saw some
third-person cover shooting we saw some
light time manipulation but all in the
context of shooting dudes in the face he
this kind of revealed a quantum break
there's more to it than that right yeah
this there's going to be way more than
that I mean once once time collapses
like that first off you can still use
your powers those time powers he got
inside one of those time grips yeah I've
got stutters has done it yeah alright so
you can still use your powers inside
those especially against things like
those enemies you can follow you into a
rift right but as you were saying before
one of the new big things is going to be
traversing the landscape as it sort of
crumbles and crashes around you yeah it
almost felt like a 3d platformer in the
vein of an uncharted because of how much
been riding a jump in there is it's
every single one it's like it's a narrow
ledge followed by a jump follow I art
wait for this thing to to move in time
because some of them are like stuck in a
loop yeah so there's things like Sam
Lake the creative director describe them
as being stuck in destructive loops yes
so like a truck carrying gravel might
get stuck over turning again and again
and again and just kind of resets every
time but it'll it'll be pulling
obstacles into your past and unless you
freeze it you're going to get fatima be
right or you can try timing it run past
as best you can which in some ways
reminded me of like Mario trying to
avoid a swamp coming down to crush his
head yeah you have that same thought
definitely but it looked like as he was
sprinting through he was like pausing
time quickly so it was like look for the
gap post
go and then and then was able to make it
through these stutters like visually
look really very incredible yeah I mean
one of the things that that Sam was
pointing out to us was as the stutter
happened you know it you might feel
inclined to sort of hurry right towards
your objective go like I definitely need
to get there but then you can kind of
take your time and there's a bit where
he's sort of like when / and explored
and there was a like I think you know
like a wife pulling her husband who'd
just been shot by by monarchs the evil
corporation evil Corp and you know she's
holding him and he can sort of like hear
these sort of like time whispers you
know of her like agony is like her
husband's dying in her arms and right
you can sort of explore around and just
just see and traverse through this
amazing rendered environment yeah yeah
and it looks crazy especially like what
we saw where the whole bridge is falling
apart and there's so much debris and he
has to traverse like the wreckage as its
plummeting like at one point he jumped
across like to freeway signs yeah it was
it was like visually looks really cool
the jury is out as toward like how much
the linear niss will kind of like way
down on players what's pretty bombastic
you know all of the all of the
platforming around just was like okay
here's another one oh it's saying it's
really appreciative on the eye there's
kind of a mind [ __ ] yeah exactly that
and yeah after a while I was like wow
this is pretty heavy but it was quite
good when he got into the the combat
with the with the heavies who were in
the
gone to the end stutter stutter stutter
hello they were you know in the stutter
with him and he was able to use objects
that were frozen in the stutter to sort
of hurl at these heavies and then put
back the answer is like delicately
replace back into the you know huge
explosion that it frozen yeah so I mean
all together just to wrap it up a little
bit it is to game with some really cool
ideas like visually very striking and
interested in the story gameplay itself
I need to see more of it yeah I
definitely want to play more of it at
the very least well they they did say
that there's going to be other bits like
that you know where you're forcing time
to move through that I'm gonna be quite
as you know overwhelming right but you
know we look forward to seeing that when
the time comes yeah yes we'll find out
yeah